الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قال
سيرالي ساك رئيس الاداره العسكريه
الاوكراني في ان عدد المصابين في القصف
الروسي الصاروخي للمدينه قد بلغ تسعه جرحى
وتامت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات
الروسيه باستهداف مدينه
والبنيه التحتيه وقالت ان القوات الروسيه
نفذت 11 غاره جويه وقصفت الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
بثمانيه وثلاثين مقذوفا من رجمات الصواريخ
خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
لان الجيش
الاوكراني من صد محاولات القوات الروسيه
التقدم في
الايمانكا بينما قامت القوات الروسيه بقصف
قرى وبلدات في مناطق كوبيانسك
واشار بيان الهيئه الاوكرانيه الى ان
قواتها لا تزال مستمره في شن هجمات على
محوري
في مقاطعه
مقابل اعلنت القوات الروسيه احباط
محاولتين للقوات الاوكرانيه للتقدم باتجاه
هم وان استهدفت بالمدفعيه والطيران وحدات
للواء الميكانيكي الثالث في الجيش
الاوكراني الذي كان يحاول التقدم باتجاه
المنطقه واضافت قوات المركز في الجيش
الروسي ان تشكيلاتها احبطت سته محاولات
للقوات الاوكرانيه لاستعاده المناطق التي
خسرتها باتجاه الايمان وتمكنت دفاعاتهم
الجويه من اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات وصاروخين من
طراز هاي مارس
اما داخل الاراضي الروسيه فقد اعلن نائب
في مجلس الدوم
الروسي عن انفجار عبوه الناسفه في مصفاه
نفط بمدينه سماره جنوبيه روسيا دون وقوع
اصابات كما اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه
اصابه 15 شخصا نتيجه انفجار في مقهى في
مدينه تاكن روجا بمقاطعه روستوفا الجنوبيه
البلاد
من جانبه قال حاكم المقاطعه ان الانفجار
قد يكون ناجما
معنى من كرامه كمراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم ومن دنيتس كمراسل الجزيره
وما اسفر عنه
نعم في الواقع مريم بنظره شامله على
الواقع الاوكراني يمكن القول والجزم بان
لغه الميدان ولغه السياسه هنا في اوكرانيا
تتناغمان وتنسجمان بشكل كبير هذا الامر
ياتي من خلال البيانات والتصريحات
العسكريه الصادره عن هيئه الاركان وعن ما
يتلخض عنه المعارك التي تدور على طول خط
الجبهه وايضا على مستوى السياسي من خلال
التصريحات الاخيره
وهو مدير مكتب زيلنسكي الذي اشار الى ان
الصيغه الوحيده المقبوله اوكرانيا للسلام
هي صيغه تعود الى حدود عام 91 لحظه اعلان
استقلال اوكرانيا وبالتالي ضمن خطين تسير
المواجهه الاوكرانيه الخط الاول سياسي
يشدد على كامل الحدود وصولا الى عام 91 اي
من ضمنها شبه جزيره القرم وكل المناطق
التي اعلنت اوكرانيا اعلنت روسيا ضمها
والخط الثاني المرتبط بوقائع الميدان على
مستوى وقائع الميدان يمكن الحديث عن هذا
القصف الذي طال بالامس
انطلاق على مدينه باخموت في محاوله منها
لتحقيق مكسب رمزي واستراتيجي في ان من
خلال استعاده السيطره على هذه المدينه
ايضا الحديث الاوكراني يتمحور على
كوبياسكو لمان حيث تؤكد القوات الاوكرانيه
بانها تصد كافه الهجمات التي تقوم بها
القوات الروسيه في تلك المناطق بالاضافه
الى مارينكا وافديافكا وايضا جافولوجيا
عمليا عثمان المراوحه هي سيده الموقف
ويمكن قول ان عمليات الكار والفرق بين
الطرفين لم تؤدي حتى الان الى متغير كبير
على مستوى خط الجبهه نعم المراوحه نور
الدين في ظل محاولات من الجانبين للتقدم
في الاثناء ماذا تقول القوات الانفصاليه
المواليه لروسيا
نعم عثمان في ظل المواجهات الحاميه الوطيس
من الشمال الى الغرب الى الجنوب يبدو ان
الحديث الان هو عن تغيير قواعد اللعبه
العسكريه من يكسب مساحات اكثر ومن يحقق
انتصارات اكثر يبدو ان روسيا بدات تستوعب
ما تخطط له القوات الاوكرانيه خاصه اذا ما
نظرنا بعين الاعتبار الى ما حدث امس في
هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه داخل العمق
الروسي بروستدف وبشرق روسيا
عبر صواريخ وعبر مسيرات بمحافظه موسكو
وكذلك عبر متفجرات في شرق في شرق روسيا
اذا هذه القواعد ربما قد تدفع القوات
الروسيه الى اعاده بناء سياسه هجوميه
السياسه الهجوميه ربما قد ترتكز على
العديد من المعطيات التي قد يتحدث عنها
القاده الروس القاده العسكريين هنا هناك
استهداف لمراكز القياده والتحكم ويبدو ان
الاستهداف الصاروخي الذي انطلق امس
يشكل احدى هذه القواعد قواعد الرد الروسي
باعتبار ان روسيا قالت بانها استهدفت مقرا
لجهاز الامن الفيدرالي الاوكراني وبالتالي
هو احد مراكز القياده والعمليه بالنظر
الروسي وهو ما تبدا ابو عليه القوات
الروسيه حينما تستهدف قواعد اخرى او مخازن
ذخيره سواء او في ميكولايب حينما تقول بان
استهدفت
مخازن لصواريخ او للطائرات المسيره او حتى
فرض سيطرتها على البحر الاسود لكن بكل
تاكيد عثمان هذا لا يمكن ان يغفل عنه ما
يقع على الميدان يحدث من تقدم الان القوات
الروسيه يبدو ان تركيزها الاساسي منصب على
الجهه الغربيه والجهه الشماليه في كوبيانس
كالحديث اليوم على ان الجيش الروسي احدث
نوعا من التقدم غربيه لمان باتجاه ووصل
الى نهر اسكيل وكذلك الى بعض المناطق
الجنوبيه لكن بكل تاكيد بشكل او باخر
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تتقدم وربما
هناك فقد لبعض المساحات بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه باتجاه شكرا من دنيا نور الدين
الدغير ومن كراماتورس كمراسل الجزيره مازن